[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal
astrophysicist and this is going to be a
cosmic aquarius edition the ever popular
format
that we started many years ago and it
just keeps going strong
uh and today's topic is going to be the
multiverse
i got with me my co-host chuck hey neil
how are you
chuck nice you know you're getting such
a schooling here
with all this cosmic knowledge yes we
have to give you a degree
of your own no no no because then that
that you know normally once you get the
degree
that means that your time at the
institution is over unless you start
paying more money
okay so they kick you out the front door
right okay
so i'm just going to continue to i'm
just staying at school forever that's a
lifelong learner that's it
just stay in school well this topic
is in part celebration for the release
of the
second start talk book and guess what
that book is called
chuck um let me take a stab at it
could it possibly be cosmic queries
cosmic queries
inspired by this very format and they're
questions that people just ask that are
so deep and so interesting and not all
of them can we get to
it on a podcast and so we have to like
take it to the book
and so there's a whole section in that
book
on the multiverse nice yeah yeah and i
learned
almost everything i know about the
multiverse from our guest
today and that is the one and the only
max
tegmark max welcome back i mean i've had
you i've had you in other events at the
museum for hayden planetarium
um panels and things it's just always
good to know you're in arms reach of us
thank you but you know you just said
something dubious you said the one and
only max peg mark and if you take the
multiverse seriously
i'm not the one and only damn i just got
schooled on my first sentence
but max we go way back i mean when you
were at the institute for advanced study
and i was postdocking at princeton i
think that's when i first met you and i
followed your career
it's been a brilliant melange of topics
that are just so interesting
and and the multiverse is the least
among them that i have found interesting
in your career so we'll have to have you
back for other topics for sure plus
chuck wow that is
that is a serious compliment if if
you know what i mean if the universe is
a side it's a
game multiple universes are
the least interesting thing like
i'm sorry i'm leveling with you here wow
to be honest guys it has been especially
my side gig
all along just so i wouldn't tank my
career with it because like when i was a
grad student
i was already fascinated by this but
nobody else seemed to be and it was
generally considered a bit too fringe so
i played the multiverse very close to my
chest
and i didn't even i even wrote some
papers when i was a grad student i
didn't show my advisor until after he
had signed my phd thesis
under a pseudonym john doe yes okay
oh that's so funny and it's so weird how
now gradually
some of these topics have actually come
in a bit from the cold and gone from
being just um
considered career ending to being things
that consider legitimate scientific
controversies that we actually
talk about openly at physics conferences
so you're a professor of physics at mit
of course the massachusetts institute of
technology
basically up the street in cambridge
massachusetts
and and uh chuck i've always been
jealous of this man's name it's like
movie star max tegmark it is starring
it does it's you know it it it could be
either
the star of the show or the producer
this is a max ted mark
introductions yeah it works it works
either way
although all of all the above right and
and max you've got a couple of books
under your belt at least uh
one of my favorites is our mathematical
universe where you argue that everything
is math and if everything is math
someone could have programmed it that
way and so a brilliant exercise there
and of course
life 3.0 um where you're exploring the
future
of what we even think of as life and
i've enjoyed both of those books so
thanks for
i think of them as a gift to
civilization to share in
how you think about this world and i
enjoyed the conversation that i heard on
npr
about your book about about
mathematical universe okay but now we
have the guy
we got him ourselves exactly we'll have
to share him so
actually i just have to ask you a trivia
question that i changed the name of that
book in the last second
for reasons we're going to talk about
now the first title was the mathematical
universe
and then i thought that's so arrogant if
we really believe that there are other
universes
we shouldn't just say the universe our
ours
we should talk about be more humble and
acknowledge that it might just
that our universe might not be the only
one
okay all right so it's just like so we
went through a brief
last-minute title change so that you
wouldn't
sound like an a-hole right we used to
talk about
the solar system and then we realized
oops there are others right
yeah or or the universe and i'm we're
not saying that anymore it's our
universe i don't like that
yeah it's it's a good it's a good shift
for that you change the universe into
the humble verse
that's cool ooh humble verse very good
chuck making up words on the spot
for humility in general i think homo
sapiens yeah well
yeah it's so max tell me what motivated
people
to you and your you know either you
early on when you were doing this
sort of under the cover of night to what
is now mainstream
research on the multiverse what
motivated it
well i think first of all throughout
human history you know we've
had this epiphany again and again that
hey
stuff is bigger than we thought and we
you know we used to go in it to it with
this hubristic assumption that
all we knew about what was all there was
kind of like an ostrich with the head of
the sound and then people realized by
the way the corollary to
it's bigger than we thought is we're
littler than we thought
exactly we realized actually flip side
of that coin we're part of this
huge we're standing on this huge round
ball in space which in turn is just part
of this gigantic solar system part of
the galaxy
part of a cluster of galaxies part of
the supercluster part of
this that we then would call our
universe and and uh you know
why stop there so people started
wondering could there be still more
and the earliest people got into much
more trouble you know than i ever did in
grad school like giordano bruno
400 years ago started talking about how
maybe space went on forever
and you know what happened to him right
yeah he was
burned at the stake upside down with a
with a something plugged into his mouth
wow
so that even in death he could not
repeat
these heresies wow talk about that they
drove a stake into his mouth so that
even when he died you know you know
that's what i liked about that time the
overkill
overkill everything was overkill
so you know now you know i went to campo
de fiore actually in rome where this
happened and i started to think you know
compared to that that just getting
burned on the job market there's a lot
less of a
threat so we're making some progress and
it's a little bit of progress
but just to be clear that square that uh
in in italy there is in all fairness
there is a statue to him
where he's looking very solemn but it's
a very honorific statue in his memory
yeah it is absolutely smart small
consolation for being burned at the
stake
and uh you know i'll take life you keep
your statue is that what you're telling
thank you
thank you exactly but but you asked this
very good question what drove us to
these things and
it's basically just uh natural logical
steps it's just you know euclid himself
postulated that space as infinites right
when and when we were kids and we
started wondering does this space go on
forever it seemed pretty natural that
there wouldn't just be an end to it
right so if you just take that idea
logically then that means that the part
we can see right this
is finite because light has only reached
us
from the spherical region that it could
get here from during the 13.8 billion
years since our big bang so
if that's what we call our universe then
by definition there are others other
regions of space
just as big just as cool and uh it's
sort of hard to dismiss
right now we don't i don't have a single
astrophysics colleague anymore i think
space magically ends right at that edge
and in fact you can just wait one day
and you see some more
light arriving from farther away right
and then
and then so that's what i call the level
one multiverse
just other regions of space that we
haven't had any access to
well so initially it wasn't that people
were motivated
to try to answer some other question
they just more fully explored
what we were already thinking and
already knew to be true about the
universe
so in that sense it's not some epiphany
it's just an extension of what we're
already thinking is that a fair way to
think about your level one multiverse i
think so and
i think a lot of the pushback honestly
wasn't really based on science so much
but based on arrogant hubris you know
the reason pope urban viii or whatever
was so pissed at galileo
you know wasn't because he had a good
scientific argument but he would like
we were so stuck to the idea that we
everything cir
orbits around us you know we humans are
so important
and we didn't like to be demoted to just
being an average planet and an average
solar system orbiting a galaxy et cetera
et cetera
and i think we see still a little bit of
that today some people
argue that they don't like this idea of
reality being even bigger just because
it makes
their egos feel even smaller
after the last four years i i can't
imagine that people would actually
have hold to those sentiments
all right so uh what i don't know
because i haven't quizzed people is what
are they thinking of when they hear
multiverse and
my sense is they're thinking it's maybe
a parallel universe that you might be
able to
to sort of move between at some distant
future time
uh so is there any truth to the concept
of a parallel universe
in the way it's commonly thought of in
the public is there an evil chuck
somewhere
except with a goatee oh you already have
a goatee
is there a clean shaven
you are the evil chuck chuck oh my god
you're a good chuck
oh my god that's right just think that
through
what's incredibly confusing here is that
different people
mean different things when they say
universe and they mean they're talking
about different kinds of
uh and in fact i remember once very
vividly martin reese had organized a
conference in his house
about these forbidden topics and i just
heard chuck these are kind of friends we
have that you get that
you know you get invited for tea and you
solve the issues of the universe
okay you know this was considered pretty
taboo back then but because martin was
organizing it people still came and
behaved and but i noticed that two
people were arguing about the multiverse
and i realized
they're talking past each other one guy
was talking about
what we call the inflationary multiverse
which is just really big
space and we can get back to that
another guy was talking about the
quantum multiverse and they thought they
were talking about the same thing so i
felt i have
i stood up and said hey wait a minute
aren't there actually three different no
four different kinds of multiverse that
we should give different names to to not
confuse ourselves so much and then i
wrote that up and and the book you men
mentioned so what i call
first of all our universe isn't all of
space it's just this part of space
but just to be clear the book that
you're talking about is
uh you you post you posted something
it's online which is a very
clean and clear exposition of the
multiple levels
of the multiverse and that's what we
referenced
when we included when we fleshed out our
section on the multiverse
in cosmic query so i just want to be
clear that
you know you're not just pulling this
out of your ass this is you've thought
about this for a long time
so so i think it's very important to
just yeah
be clear on what we're talking about
yeah thank you so if
by our universe we mean what astronomers
call our observable universe
there's just a spherical region of space
from which light has reaches then what i
call the level one multiverse is just
other parts of space that are so far
away that light hasn't reached us yet
level two multiverse is what you get if
you take seriously
alan guth and andre linde and others and
the theory of inflation
that made our space so big which says
that far far
away in the same space now you have
something much more diverse
than you might have thought well even um
the number of
different kind of quarks could be
different or the sort of forces that
are different then we can talk about why
and then there's this third kind and
that's what gets more into the parallel
evil feeling thing which has to do with
studying not the big but the very small
studying quantum mechanics where
you can argue and people love arguing
about that at physics conferences that
in some sense our reality
feels like it's splitting out into
parallel branches
and that's the whole if that is true you
can tap into that
weirdness by building quantum computers
and then finally there's the fourth one
which is so weird that
almost nobody except myself believe in
it which is the biggest
and i think all of this is basically
russian dolls
they're nested they're all inside of
each other right you start with
our universe many of those that's level
one
many of those that makes level two many
of those makes level three
and many of those makes the ultimate one
the the fourth level
so these are these are these are
multiverses of multiverses
that's right that's right but the only
one that ever gets any real attention
is that kind of you know
um tree limb version that you put pic
that you depicted this splintering
uh well you know where there's so many
different uh
infinite paths that are separate
yet existing simultaneously that seems
to be the one that
captures the imagination of every sci-fi
writer and
and even rick and morty which is like a
hugely popular
show i mean it's like it's it's you know
it because i think you could do so much
with it you know there's an
infant number of ricks and they're all
geniuses
so they you know so i mean you have an
unlimited uh
um reservoir of stories to tell chuck
chuck
max is rick we're gonna take a quick
break when we come back we'll go
straight into our
questions from our patreon members when
star talk
cosmic queries returns we're back
cosmic queries the multiverse edition
and and uh max we've got max tegmark
professor physics from
mit i've known him for 25 years and no
longer 30 years i think
and yeah yeah yeah in every universe
in every universe thank you chuck for
clarifying that
uh i'd max you into so many things uh
into ai
into most recently you've been thinking
about news
and the biases and news we have to get a
whole other show on that one
um but i just love the work you're doing
it's fun to follow you
uh from afar and so we've got you on
this program to talk about the
multiverse because that's one of your
many expertise and chuck
you've got questions for us let's do it
okay let's just jump right into uh all
the questions that we have taken
from our patreon patrons the people who
support
us uh out of their substance to keep our
show going
so thank you guys for your support and
if you uh
are listening to this and you want to be
a patreon member go to patreon.comtalk
and uh and give us some support and
maybe i'll reach her
maybe maybe i don't know that's how
you're going to end this yeah yeah
maybe i'll figure it out maybe i'll
think about reading you no
of course i'm joking of course i'll read
your letter and i'll push you your name
no doubt okay
no doubt here we go give it to me all
right this is eric gross he says hello
fellow earthicans uh said fellow eric
because that's my middle name
oh ericans oh yes
either way can you explain the
mind-boggling
idea of
infinite infinities
oh wow wow
wow that's a great question how about
this wait so max let's let's
let's start simple and let me ask you
what does it mean
for one infinity to be bigger than
another
and then let's take it from that into
that directly into the quest let's drive
the truck right into that question
one inch wait a minute guys give me one
sec
wait what chuck great questions
i gotta get this little pipe here
you know if we're going to talk about
one infinity being bigger than another
i'm just saying i need to i need to be
prepared
the pipe has to be right there okay
exactly if you have a pile of oranges
and you have a pile of apples and you
want to know
is it the same number of apples as
oranges the way you do it
is if you can pair up each apple with
exactly one orange
you say the two numbers are the same so
now play that game with infinities
and weird stuff happens um let me
for example you might think that there
are more numbers one two three four five
then there are even numbers you know two
four six
but they're actually the same because
you can pair them up i can pair up one
with two
i can pair up eight with 16 i pair up
every number with one that's twice as
big which is always even
so it's very counter-intuitive so for a
while mathematicians start but just to
be clear you just said something but not
everyone knows this
yeah max that twice
any number any whole number is always an
even number
thanks for clarifying yeah yeah that is
always the case so
you can't take twice anything and end up
twice a whole number and get an odd
number
so when you say twice the number that's
always even that's a that's a
fundamental fact about mathematics okay
that's right and actually
the quite weird conclusion is that
some infinities which intuitively would
seem like they're much bigger are
actually all the same size and some
mathematicians start to think maybe all
infinities are the same
size but then george cantor came along
and said no
there are some infinities they're even
bigger and he's proved famously that
the number of real numbers like 3.1415
with infinitely many decimals
that they're actually more of those than
the numbers you can count
and after that people have realized that
there's this whole tower of infinity so
what that what's that got to do with
parallel universes and this question
well it's got a lot to do actually with
the level one and the level two
multiverse because
chuck has to take a toke
[Laughter]
took break yes exactly
so far this is great this is great take
a deep
breath because i'm going to tell you one
of the things that i find the weirdest
this is one of the weirdest things i
believe to be true and if max finds it
weird
brace yourself right exactly that it is
actually impossible it is according to
einstein's theory of general relativity
possible to take a little piece of space
just finite
and inside of there make an infinite
space that doesn't stick out anywhere
and actually infinitely and make many
different infinite spaces inside of this
finite thing
it's a bit like the ending of the men in
black i don't want to spoil it for those
who haven't seen the film
the movie around long enough don't worry
about it so so
alan guth andre linde and others came up
with this
most popular theory we have so far for
what put the bang into our big bang
right and
made this expanding uh universe of ours
starting with something tinier than an
atom it's very very big
and the ultimate party trick is inside
of this tiny region
they can not only make one space which
when you live in it in
feels infinite that's the level one
multiverse for you in there
so it has room for infinitely many of
our universes
but you can have infinitely many of
those
within there and uh so you can have an
infinite number
of infinitely large universes in a
finite universe
basically that's why it feels so utterly
weird and the way that
general relativity kind of pulls this
trick
is because even though it was a finite
volume of space
it has an infinite amount of future time
to play with and
it keeps stretching the space and then
general relativity has this funny thing
where it can kind of mix up space and
time
so that for someone who lives inside
this what they consider to be space
was something that you might have
considered a little bit of time and
i don't want to get too nerdy about this
but you know einstein told us
that what really we should only now are
you saying you don't want to get too
nerdy
this only just occurred to you now i
think you already blew it
but einstein told us right that we
shouldn't think of reality as a
three-dimensional
place or stuff happens but rather as
a time being just a four dimension
fourth dimension and this never changing
place called space time
so if like if if life is a movie then uh
space time is the whole dvd and
basically because you have this infinite
future time to mess with
if you can sort of bend your definition
of what space is in there
this is how alan gooth and andre linde
and alex willinkin and others have have
demonstrated this apparently crazy thing
that maybe everything we see here
in infinity of infinities could actually
ultimately be emerging inside of this
little bubble
so just to clarify your dvd analogy what
you're saying is we live as prisoners of
the present
transitioning from our past to our
future so we experience
a moment in time and many places in
space
but if you have the whole dvd of the
movie then your entire timeline is
manifest
in that place all at once all at once
all the time
of your life is in that dvd
you can have random access to it if you
have
if you can move throughout the time
coordinate is that fair
reference to how you use the concept of
dvd it is
it is and yeah that's right
einstein even told some of his friends
that they shouldn't worry
about much about his death because he
argued that it's just
from the space-time perspective an
illusion it's not like because i'm
already dead man
it's so are you we're all dead man
and we're not i haven't even been born
yet man
and i'm dead what it's pretty weird
chuck i mean i'm sure
sometimes people come up to you when
they're lost and ask hey excuse me but
uh
where am i right but they never come and
ask
when am i right in colloquial english we
treat time as a very different sort of
thing as space
whereas when we say what's the time
that's actually very arrogant
just like talking about the universe or
the solar system
the what is the time i mean that that's
saying that somehow the
the instant when we're having this
experience is the only time
i mean all the other times past and
present in space time have just as much
claim to be
real they certainly felt real to people
who had
experiences then right so if we want to
be a little bit more rigorous we should
always go ask people excuse me
when am i
what you are right now at this
particular time having having this
experience
wow okay so that doesn't have the
arrogance that it otherwise would yeah
by asking what is the
time i mean it's like going up and
saying what is the place
right of course where i am is the only
place
all right chuck give me some more
questions all right well that was
way too way to kick things off that is
something else
all right let's move on to uh you know
this that that other level you talk
about this is
chris hampton could the parallel
universe
theory and the multiverse theory be
combined
for example we are living in a universe
with billions of other organisms but
what if
each organism in the universe is itself
a universe on a relative scale
each one thus containing billions
of organism so on and so on so he's
taking your nesting doll
and breaking it all the way down to
every single organism right but yeah
he's thinking
um i mean i so so max if we have as a
lead into that
the early concept of the atom where
people said oh my gosh
atoms have structure and there's a
nucleus and there's electrons
orbiting so that's just like the solar
system so maybe
it's like turtles all the way down so
how do we go from
any understanding of scales of
if everything's just on a different
scale rather than something that's a
completely different universe
unto itself yeah very good question we
see of course in nature this
really beautiful hierarchy right you
have some
some quarks stuck together into neutrons
and protons they're stuck together into
this bit thing we call it
nucleus stuck together in an atom and
then you can make molecules and cells
and you can make neil degrasse tyson and
this
society and the planet and galaxy et
cetera
what's different about the hierarchy of
universes is
is uh it's not just that the hierarchy
exists but by definition
i like to define the universe our
universe
as everything that we could possibly
have any access to with unlimited
funding and
never mind other stuff that's in the way
right
so if you are if you look at for example
if you're once if you're one person in a
society there are a lot of people you
haven't met
but you could in principle meet them so
they're not part of another universe
you could in principle go to uruguay
even if you've never been there
right but you can never go 100 billion
light years
in that direction even if you wanted to
it's it's just
off limits to you so we're a bit more
that's basically the definition i think
is helpful about
universe um and uh some people otherwise
we'd use the term
sort of poetically or metaphorically
like the cell is a universe unto itself
yeah you know so i think that's fair
poetically but you're saying from the
world of physics
no that's not how we use the term yeah
exactly and i mean it's
whatever we need to have we should have
a word
for everything we can access it's very
important for us especially in the
future both if we're curious that's the
limits of what we can
observe and if we're ambitious that's
also setting
roughly the limits of where we could
ever go in the future so if you don't
want to call it universe
call it schmooniverse or make up another
word for it but it deserves to be called
something right
and which where space i think is a word
that's better used to actually describe
all of space and it's not the same thing
space is probably bigger
than our universe but we have confirmed
that chuck lives in the schmooniverse
just
yeah it's clear the smoother verses it's
where all dismissive people live
universe schmooniverse
what happened it could at least be the
universe
or the two i i don't mind a tuna verse
now you're making me hungry
uh well chris hampton actually uh it
looks like he
from what you just said is speaking of
smoking it's that whole
hey man there's a universe in my
thumbnail like
that whole vibe that's that seems to be
where he's right
all right cool so let's uh by the way
again that was reminiscent of
the ending of men in black with the
galaxy on the belt of orion
which was the tag line there but yeah
you got to see the movie
but it is you i like what you said neil
the reason people use it poetically in
that sense
is because we think we refer things
poetically as a universe unto its own
basically if it really
is doing its own thing and not
interacting with
the rest right which is what we're
trying to capture scientifically here
okay so now i should i i gotta i wanna
ask my own question but i don't wanna i
don't wanna take up these people's time
chuck are you a patreon member if not
shut the hell up and read the next
question
okay well neil i got to tell you you
have bested me sir
that was a damn good point
oh my god hold on now i gotta go online
right now
i gotta get on patreon right now so i
can ask my question
all right here we go this is uh
oh man you really got me with that one
okay this is curtis
um curtis lee uh zeidel hack
uh i think uh yeah he says um
first and foremost for formers my name
is pronunce zado hawk okay so i
okay i was wrong but i got it close
conceptually i do not really understand
how a multiverse
affects our universe
what is the most important effect
on our universe and i'm going to
paraphrase that and say is there any
observational evidence
right that such a thing exists and we're
going to get to that
in the next segment we've got to take a
quick break cliffhanger so
when we come back more star talk cosmic
queries with my long time friend and
colleague
multiverse assist
max tegmark on star talk
we're back star talk cosmic queries
multiverse edition
or is it the shmultyverse we're trying
to figure out
creative naming of these things i got
max tag mark max are you on social media
um tag mark on twitter tag mark
there you go nice the only tech mark in
the world
that's it that doesn't even need a first
let just tag mark like
well he's like you believe in the
multiverse then there's undoubtedly some
other planet out there with someone
who looks exactly like me and talks like
me but the first one you come to will
probably be named schmegmark or
something else because you know it's
if you take seriously this idea that
space is just infinite
and started out a little bit differently
in different places it's much more
likely to get
someone who is kind of sort of like me
but not exactly
right okay there you go well
i mean in the in the meantime uh uh
that's not a problem for twitter
there's that scene where they have the
whole room of a million monkeys typing
away on a typewriter
trying to get the works of shakespeare
and so they finally get one it was just
like
to be or not to shrink the wreck
yeah you know there's about a google
particles you have to put together right
in our observable universe so one with a
hundred zeros
so you actually have to try about a
google plex
times which is one with a google zeros
after it until you get it right which is
why
your nearest clone might be ridiculously
far away so i love the question you just
asked before we got
cut off there about what's the evidence
for this is this just
silly uh pub uh
beer speculation or is there is this
science
did chuck who asked that that would be
curtis uh zyto hawk
yeah he's wondering do we feel see this
other universe and so another the
official way to say that is
do we have experimental evidence that
they exist right or this is just what
you talk about
at the at the beer halls yeah
so it's a really great question because
by definition
of the what you mean by uh universe
you are not affected by things outside
of it so isn't that by definition
untestable
and the interesting thing is no that's
not true
first of all if you just take the theory
that space is actually much bigger than
we thought and
with more stuff in it right
if that's false that would mean that
actually things kind of
end at exactly the edge that we can see
now that's very testable you just wait a
little bit
and then light from farther away reaches
you and keeps coming into view
and so we've already falsified that many
times over
now there's a more profound way in which
you can test this
also though we have to remember in
science right we test
theories and for theory to be testable
you don't have to be able to test
everything that it predicts just at
least one thing take einstein
it's theory of general relativity right
it predicts all sorts of stuff
that we can observe like how mercury
orbits around the sun in a lot
different way than people thought it was
supposed to because of newton
um we can test that we can test how
light is bent
by gravity et cetera but it also
predicts
what happens inside of black holes which
you know very well we cannot go and
observe but then come back and tell our
friends about it
why do we still take it seriously what
happens inside black holes
because we've this theory of general
relativity has passed so many other
tests that we could test that we also
start taking seriously its untestable
predictions
and you can't just do say well i know i
kind of like what einstein's theory
predicts for the motion of mercury and
gravitational lensing and yada yada yada
but i don't like the interior black
holes i'm just gonna opt
out of that like if i go to starbucks
and say i want my coffee but i'm going
to opt out of the caffeine and have
decaf
that's not the way science works if you
if you want to opt out of the black
holes
then go come up with your own
gravitational theory
which doesn't have black holes in it but
still succeeds in everything einstein's
theory did
that turns out to be such a tall order
that despite a lot of smart people
trying you know for 100 years
they've all failed so so what's that got
to do with the multiverse
well replace general relativity now with
the theory of inflation with that we
talked about it makes a
bunch of testable predictions it
predicts that our universe should be
expanding that it should be very uniform
but just to be clear you're not you're
not actually replacing
general relativity you're enclosing it
yeah in the in inflation isn't that
correct
correct yes thank you for correcting me
we take generativity and then we add and
it's some additional assumptions to it
that there's a certain kind of substance
there which behaves in a certain way
and then we do the math and it predicts
all sorts of things that we've tested
now successfully with great prediction
like these ripples in the microwave
background their statistical patterns
for example i've worked as you know a
lot on on trying to rule out this theory
of inflation and i've failed
and because of that we take it seriously
and we also have to then take seriously
the things inflation predicts
that we cannot test such as that space
is actually way bigger
than our universe so there you go i
think that's an excellent
excellent way to think about it so so if
the one theory has these multiple
consequences it's okay if some of them
you'll nev you can't or you never will
if the ones that you can test
turn out to be correct and you say if
this is correct i'm going to take a
stronger look over i'm going to start
thinking about this
by the way is it fair to say max that if
you explore the things you
cannot measure you might come up with a
discovery that you can measure
very true too because very often when
people have been going off and thinking
about these things which they knew they
could never test
they came it led them to ask questions
what led them back
back to a whole fresh way good test
so that's a another very good reason not
just we shouldn't think of these cool
things just because they're fun
but they often turn out to be very
useful people started thinking about
what the ultimate building blocks of
matter were and atoms and so on and
people
for a long time thought that was
completely useless but then by thinking
about that
they invented quantum mechanics which
gave us the whole com
computer technology which lets us have
this podcast now
and so on and that that's uh so
and that's another example actually of
exactly this this same question
the quantum parallel universe is of
course we can't visit them either
but quantum mechanics predict so much
else that we can test
and it turned out to be very very
difficult
to come up with a theory of physics that
predicts only
some sort of creation mechanism for our
universe that creates only the part we
can see
and then stops and doesn't make anything
more
so let me ask you this with respect to
what you're saying
chuck you're not a patreon member yet
maybe you signed up during the break
that's right you never know what i did
during the break i don't know what you
did during the break
that's right all right i'll let you slip
one and go all right so max with respect
to what you just said are there things
that we are
able to observe or at least
able to observe the forces thereof
that remain a mystery that may in some
way be
attached to the multiverse theory
i would say is that what we just
answered is that
are you saying chuck if the multiverse
is what it is is there some piece of a
dangling and visible in our own universe
yes that we're observing that that but
what we're actually observing but it's
still a mystery
like you know are there mysteries that
aren't that are observable that
i got to chuck i'm going to read i'm
going to read i'm going to recast your
question you're ready chuck
okay are there deep mysteries in our own
universe that could themselves
be evidence of a multiverse and we have
yet to put the two together how's that
that's what i'm saying okay that's not
what you said you you mentioned
it but i didn't mangle it enough that
you didn't know what i was saying
and i will answer it with a resounding
yes okay take dark energy for example we
all know
by now that we have no clue what 95
of our universe is made of and most of
it is made of this weird stuff called
dark energy
and what's really odd about it is when
you work
when you work out exactly how much there
is there is in the sort of most natural
units of measurement that we would do in
physics we get this number which is
0.00000 with 123 zeros and then
a one and we wonder like why is that
it turns out if you look closer that if
you have a little bit more we would all
be dead
it wouldn't be any galaxies actually
ever formed and if you had less so this
was a bit negative we would be inside of
a black hole by now and also not having
this conversation so
why is it that our universe was so
fine-tuned that the amount of dark
energy was dialed into this
that very special value that let us have
this conversation
that is one of the exact those mysteries
chuck i think that you're fishing for
here
we me some people said well tough luck
sometimes we're just lucky let's just be
grateful for it and shut up
other people said maybe this is evidence
that we were designed
either by a divine being or by some
simulator who
tuned our universe especially to be able
to have life in the parents basement
they did this yes
and then but then if you actually have
para apparently
this thing with space being very big
with parallel universes with all sorts
of different values of that
knob setting in different places
suddenly you have an actual
simple explanation for this the picture
you get then is that
the bigger space is like the sahara
desert it's mostly just the barren
wasteland with no galaxies
but in a few places you know that knob
is set just right and you have an oasis
where there is life and there are
galaxies and there is star talk you know
and surprise surprise of course that's
where we're going to be having these
conversations so but just to be clear
it's not that it was
set that way it's that if you have an
infinite or a huge number of these
universes
where the knobs are set at random right
one of those random knob settings will
be the right combination
for us it's like tuning tuning your dial
up up and down what used to be radio
kids there used to be a thing it used to
be this thing called radio
guys where you would actually tune your
dial and
like most of it was just white noise and
empty
but every once in a while you will come
across somebody talking or some music or
something like that exactly oh that is
freaking brilliant god i love science
okay okay keep going all right here we
go here we go we've got just a few
minutes left see if we can squeeze them
all in go
all right all right here we go um
he's this is woody okay
i'm going to read this because he's just
going did you pronounce his name
correctly that yeah
okay i got it right what he says what
are your thoughts on how a multiverse
could
actually begin what each one require big
bang and how many
of those would end up with a chuck being
possible
the chucker burst
whatever yes so max does everyone have a
big bang just like us that's a great
question
yeah so
i've actually had a total rethink about
the big bang concept because first i was
taught that that's the beginning
and now it's pretty clear if you take
inflation theory seriously you should
think of the big bang
just as the end of this crazy creative
inflation process
in our little part of space when things
calm down enough that you can make
galaxies involve
a kneel and a chuck and other in other
places it kind of keeps going
and so even if you have only one bang
but that it keeps going
ad infinitum you will end up having many
many different regions where it stops
and and you get what we recall a level
one multiverse you know with the
universe
so all it takes is ultimately one bang
to get it all and
and if you have each one of those places
where it stops being actually
infinite then no matter how unlikely it
is that you chuck
a rise because the particles started out
in exactly the right configurations for
your mom to meet your dad and all of
that
the probability wasn't zero because it
happened here and you're rolling the
dice infinitely many times now right
so it's guaranteed well there you go and
by the way
both my parents lost on that bet so on
the roll of that dice
i mean with by making you is that what
you're saying okay all right
believe me i was not a good kid all
right keep it going
here we go uh this is cameron bishop
hello max hello neil i've always been
curious
is it flawed to ask what's between these
universes
is that measurable space
that's a great question so between the
different level one multiverses in the
level two multiverse there's still space
but that space in between is still doing
this inflation thing and doubling its
size over and over and over ago and
in regular intervals that's why it's
impenetrable
because if you start flying through you
go for a while and now you're still
farther away from
where you're supposed to go it's
expanding faster than you can gain
distance through it
exactly exponentially okay that's great
that's super cool all right
okay here we go wait but in the quantum
multiverse they're actually whole other
space times there's not one space-time
system right
you have a quantum multiverse the level
three lives in the bigger space we call
hilbert space
which may even have infinitely many
dimensions so i hear the rents they're
out of control the hilbert's favorite
yeah
property values are just off the charts
something has to be done about hillberg
damn it
so but so what would you call what was
between
those quantum universes yeah
in the quantum case it's much more
tricky
that when quantum mechanics was first
invented people didn't know about this
this phenomena called decoherence it was
only discovered by hans dieter say in
1970 and he should be more famous
than he is which is a kind of censorship
mechanism that explains
why we don't experience all those other
weird
quantum
realities if they're actually there
basically what comes out of the math is
that these quantum
superpositions as they're called they
only survive as long as they're kept
secret
and whenever something gets really big
you know air molecules bounce off
photons bounce off and the secret is out
it's like you tell a friend they tell a
friend and so on and that's why big
things like us
always seem to only be in one place at
once and we can only experience
and measure quantum weirdness with tiny
things that can keep their
properties secret there's a chuck time
for that last toke on that pipe
yeah man i'm telling you right there
that's
wow that was that was cool
what's it called d what now the
coherence
d coherence what he's saying is that
we're so big we can only be in one place
wow he's chuck when your kids are
babbling on and you don't know what
they're saying say stop being d coherent
yeah don't be d coherent okay
quantum dummy that's worse than
incoherent you are g
coherent yeah they're just de-cohering
the whole conversation
okay chuck give me one last question and
see if max has a
sound bite in him to answer because
that's all the time we have left for it
all right all right all right all right
here we go this is j
hunt greetings neil and max uh
this is jeff from titan
my question is to tighten the moon of
the
saturn i guess you gotta love that right
my question is that means it's full of
methane gas
just so you know okay
gotta cut down on those beans man
yeah watch out for the beans right guys
on this show you better be careful where
you say you're from because otherwise
there you go all right okay he says is a
new multiverse created every time we
make a this or that
decision so the idea that the infinite
number of
possibilities are not actually
possibilities
until we make one of those possibilities
fantastic question about the level three
reminder about soundbite go on yeah yeah
sliding doors movie watch it uh
basically if you make a snap decision
that you're really torn about right
what ends up happening might come down
to the position of a single little
calcium ion somewhere in some synaptic
junction
and where depending on where it is off
the things go and you end up
with a completely different pattern
either you decide to say yes to that
date
and live happily ever after or say no
and do something different right so
that can a micro superposition can get
amplified into something that's so
different
macroscopically that this decoherence
thing comes along and makes these two
things really really separate so
in that sense yes when you make a
decision that
really could have made both ways you are
in a sense
according to if the level 3 multiverse
is real creating two parallel
realities are equally real and each one
of you is only of course aware of
one outcome and is going to think that's
all that happened oh my god oh
that is crazy i love that that is
awesome
oh my god oh right now somewhere it
means you created another chuck but
you're only this chuck
and so that's all you need that other
that other guy is actually happy and
he's having fun
i try to think about that every time i
get a parking ticket you know that
there's some other power universe
where i didn't but then i think a bit
more and realized there's another final
universe where i got towed
max we got to call it quits there it's
been a delight to have you on um it's
always great to talk to you and
probe your brain for all the fun stuff
that you're thinking about
and we'll get you on for another show
because i there's more to you than
what showed up here and i want to make
sure our audience knows all about it
so thanks for being on star talk chuck
always good to have you always a
pleasure
all right this has been star talk cosmic
query the multiverse edition
neil degrasse tyson bidding to keep
[Music]